MALE SPEAKER 1: What
could we do to improve K
through 12 education
in America the best?
BILL GATES: Well, today, if
you're motivated to learn,
if you really, really,
really want to learn,
this is an amazing
time for everyone.
Because if you have
access to Wikipedia,
if you have access to the
latest information on the web--
there's a website that I've
just been using with my kids
recently called Khan
Academy, K-H-A-N.
Just one guy doing some
unbelievable 15-minute
tutorials.
There's great college lectures
out on academicearth.org.
So if you're
motivated, now you can
go to the very best lectures.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Speaking of allocation
of society's resources, I think
you said, on your campus tour,
at least at Harvard,
that the allocation of IQ
points of our society to Wall
Street financial instruments
was higher than it needed to
be, and that some of those IQ
points should go
into other fields.
BILL GATES: Yeah.
Well if you say, OK, what
portion of society's IQ
goes into studying
great teachers
and documenting what
those great teachers do
and how you would spread those
practices, what is effectively
the R&D component in
education, it's about as close
to nil as you can imagine.
And yet, what's the
most important thing
in terms of having
a society that
has both got equality
of opportunity
and is competitive
with other countries?
It's education.
And so it's this
mind-blowing misallocation.
My favorite vignette is
that guy, Salman Khan.
He was a hedge fund guy
making lots of money,
and he quit to do these
little web videos.
And so we have moved, I'd
say, about 160 IQ points
from the hedge fund category
into the teaching many,
many people in a
leveraged way category.
So that was a good day,
the day that his wife
let him quit his job.